لا يمكن أن يستمر الحرق بالسرعة الكافية ، كان الدخان
خلفي يتصاعد باستمرار
من جميع الجثث التي تحترق ،
وهذه الصناديق هنا كلها
مليئة بأكياس الجثث الصفراء ،
فتح العمال لاحقًا تلك
الحاويات المعدنية هنا في محرقة جثث كبيرة في بكين
تكشف عن صفوف  من أكياس الجثث
أثناء تحميلها المزيد من التوابيت في
درجات الحرارة الباردة المتجمدة
تغرق محارق الجثث في المدن الكبرى
مع انتشار فيروس كورونا في أنحاء البلاد ، لكن
الصين أبلغت عن عدد قليل
من الوفيات المرغوبة منذ إعادة فتحها في أواخر
الشهر الماضي.
توفي صديقه المقرب
من الحمى ، وعادة ما
يحمل المستشفى الجثة ، لكن المستشفى أخبره
أن هناك الكثير من الجثث التي
قال إنه ينتظرها هنا لساعات
ولا يزال لا يعرف ما إذا كان
جثة صديقه يمكن حرقها اليوم.
هناك صف طويل من السيارات التي
تدور حول هذه المنطقة بأكملها في انتظار الوصول
إلى منطقة حرق الجثث هذه ، فأنا في
موقف السيارات الآن وقد
اكتمل  أنا مليء بالسيارات التي أتحدث عنها
هنا لأن هناك العديد من
حراس الأمن يقومون بدوريات في هذه
المنطقة بأكملها ويحزن أفراد الأسرة على
صور المتوفى ويخبرنا البعض من
الكاميرا أنهم يعرفون أن أحبائهم ماتوا
من فيروس كورونا وانتظروا أكثر
من يوم من أجل
تبيع المحلات المزدحمة المجاورة لحرق الجثث أشياء جنائزية
بها نقود ورقية ملابس وبيوت
وحيوانات تستخدم في الدفن تقاليد متناثرة
على جانب الطريق
تقول امرأة تبيع الزهور إنها
نفد مخزونها ، ويقول رجل يبيع الجرار
إن العمل قد قفز
حتى في المتجر و
أصبحت أراضي محارق الجثث أكثر انشغالًا ،
عادةً ، فأنت لست مشغولًا جدًا ، أطلب
من الرجل إيماءة وأخبرني أنه عادةً
لا يوجد أحد
هنا وليس فقط في بكين ،
يظهر فيديو على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي محارق جثث مزدحمة
ومنازل جنازات في جميع أنحاء البلاد
في هذا الجنازة الرئيسية في G9  يقول الرجل
إن الأمر مجنون هنا ، فهي
مليئة بعصابات السيارات
التي تحمل أجسادًا ممتدة على
طول المسافة أمام هذه
السيارة.  rematorium داخل
هذا مستشفى Cova المعين في
بكين ، كان هناك تدفق مستمر من
المرضى المسنين على الكراسي المتحركة
إلى هذا المستشفى.
covid
لكنه أنشأ هذا المستشفى ، لقد
نفدت مساحة السرير
، سألت العامل خارج هذا
المستشفى هل يموت الكثير من الناس هنا
نعم كل يوم يستجيب أسأل هل
كل هذا بسبب كوفيد نعم الأشخاص الذين يعانون من
ظروف أساسية يقول إن
الصين الآن  تمر عملية إعادة الفتح المؤلمة التي مر بها
بقية العالم
بالفعل ، لكنها لا
تشارك نفس البيانات التي تقول الحكومة الآن
إنها تضيق تعريف
وفيات كوفيد -19 فقط للمرضى الذين
ماتوا بسبب فشل الجهاز التنفسي
الناجم مباشرة عن
الفيروس الذي تحدثنا عنه.  في محارق الجثث
ربما قالوا إن أحبائهم ماتوا إذا كان
كوفيد ، لكن وفاتهم والعديد من
الآخرين لن يتم احتسابهم في الحصيلة الرسمية